- There was a moment,
probably, we were down.
It was a back-and-forth game, ish,
but they definitely had the lead.
And there was a moment where I was like,
this might be your last half,
so let's fucking go, you know?
- [Taylor Rooks:] Wow.
- Like, I actually thought that to myself.
- Oh, Sue Bird is
in the house!
Which, I recently learned,
it was almost me
saying Courtney Bird.
- Oh yeah.
- Your name was al— [Laughing]
- You've done your research.
You've done your research.
- Courtney Bird, like, doesn't even sound right.
- I know. Courtney Elizabeth.
- Oh, I don't know about that.
- Courtney Elizabeth.
- So which parent was Team Courtney?
- God, that's a good question.
I want to say—I actually don't know.
I think they were both,
it was like a joint,
yeah, a joint almost decision.
- Oh my gosh.
You know, I love, like,
how Megan [Rapinoe] said
you're Sue to the core, like 100 percent.
Like, your name is Sue Bird.
It cannot be—
- It's one word.
- Anything else.
- Yeah, it's one word, yeah.
- Yeah, it suits you. And it's Sue Brigit Bird?
- Yeah, Brigit.
- Aw, I love that.
Yeah, I heard that.
I'm like, that's probably the best decision—
- [Laughing]
- Your parents ever made
in your whole life
is making sure that you were Sue Bird
and not Courtney Bird.
I love it.
They love you here in Seattle.
- [Laughing]
- Like, every person that has asked me
why I'm in Seattle and I say,
"Oh, I'm here to interview Sue Bird."
They all freak out.
- [Laughing]
- I mean, do you feel that Seattle love all the time?
- Um, yeah. They're pretty amazing out here.
- Yeah.
It's like the perfect sports city.
They love their sports.
It's like a big small city.
Big enough where you get good restaurants,
you get good shopping,
but small enough where it's like,
kind of cozy in that way.
- Yeah. Absolutely.
- Yeah.
- Well, you know, I got to watch UConn
game here in my hotel.
- OK.
- OK, what is it like
watching a tournament game [laughing]
for UConn with Sue Bird?
- Uh, you know, when I'm in,
like, the privacy
of my own home, I definitely get into it.
I'm, like, up and down
and over here and over there
and jumping and yelling and cheering.
My hand actually hurts
from Megan's high-fives.
I was like, babe, you gotta take your rings off.
- [Laughing]
- You're actually—it's like starting to hurt
cuz she gets into it.
And that game was like, instant classic.
So there were so many highs and lows.
- Mmhmm.
- So as a fan, it was really fun to watch.
Forget UConn winning, losing.
NC State easily could have won that.
Just as like a fan,
that was such a great game.
- Yeah, cuz that was
the thing about that game.
And I said it was like, UConn played great,
NC State played great,
but then we just ran out of time.
- Ran out of time.
- I mean, it was just
UConn happened to outlast them.
Paige Bueckers is so good.
- [Laughing]
- What do you see when you look at Paige?
- Um, God. I see, like, an endless ceiling,
just like literally
definition of sky's the limit
because she's clearly talented, right?
She definitely has that, like,
clutch gene, you know,
game's on the line, doesn't care.
Just goes at—although in regulation,
I was like, Paige, go get the ball.
What are you doing?
I don't know if anybody else felt that way.
- Yeah. [Laughing]
- And then luckily, she turned it on in overtime.
- Yeah.
- But yeah, she has like all of those things
that I feel like a lot of us
athletes get asked about. Like, how—
so, how does one get the clutch gene?
Or, how does one, you know,
thrive in late-game situations?
There's really no answer.
Sometimes it's just that you have it
or you don't.
- Yeah.
- And she has it, but obviously, she's young.
So that's why I say that
about the ceiling.
Like, the ceiling is the roof, you know.
- Totally.
[Both laughing]
Shoutout MJ.
But no, I agree.
That's the thing with her.
It is so innate.
And when you think about that game
and, you know, some others,
the only thing that for her
probably working on is just,
I'm the person that has to take over
and like her kind of realizing it
cuz that's what I thought
when I watched the game too.
Like, this is the moment
you have to go be Paige.
And she did it, but she did it eventually.
Yeah.
- Yeah.
And I do—I mean, you have to give her
credit too. Like, had midseason surgery,
trying to get her everything, like her mojo—
- Yeah.
- Her vibe, her health back,
so it's not an easy moment.
So hopefully,
hopefully, this kind of propels her
for the Final Four
because that's not gonna be an easy game.
- Yeah.
- And Dorka [Juhász] with her wrist. [Gagging]
- Bad, yeah.
That was just so sad.
- That was disgust—oh my God, that was tough.
- Yeah.
- So that's gonna hurt them.
So they're gonna need everybody
to step up.
And Paige, like I said,
hopefully this sets her off.
- What does Paige do better than you?
Better than that UConn you?
- Oh God.
Probably everything—
- Yeah.
- Better than me.
Um, we're totally different. Yeah.
She—honestly, if I were to pick one thing,
her confidence is just crazy.
And it's not that I'm not confident,
but I think, like, all athletes
at different points
can struggle with that.
It's very commonplace.
Whereas she feels—
she's more similar to Diana [Taurasi] in that way.
And I'm not comparing them,
but that's like something I see similar.
It's just this, this,
this confidence that comes from—
comes from what? Comes from doing it
or you just have it, but it's there.
- Yeah. It's just like this swag.
- Yes.
- They're unfazed.
Yeah, absolutely.
- Right.
- It's interesting to hear
you talk about confidence
and you say that is a thing that, like,
you have struggled with and athletes struggle with.
- Of course.
- What—give me an example
of what you mean by that.
- I mean, I think—oh God,
like a stupid one would just be,
you know, you have some players
go into games and whether they make their
first shot, make their first five shots
or miss their first 10,
they just keep going. They keep shootin'.
They have—they are unfazed,
like you just said, doesn't bother them.
I internalize some of that, right?
So if I come out—this is
hopefully not as much now,
but definitely when I was younger,
like if I come out,
miss a few shots,
I might be a little more, you know, tentative.
Maybe I had a couple turnovers.
I might be a little more careful.
I don't have, like,
that just blind confidence.
- Yeah.
- Like, I definitely internalize mistakes.
Yeah.
- How do you get better at that?
- Whew. Million-dollar question.
- [Laughing] Yeah.
- Um, I do feel really lucky that the way
Coach [Geno] Auriemma coaches you in college,
he essentially sets
you up to fail at all times.
So the more times you beat him,
the more times you beat the drill,
whatever's happening in practice, that's where,
like, that internal confidence comes from.
And I think what happened
over time for me is I kind of have found
this place I can rest in, if you will,
this space of, like, law of averages,
almost, you know.
Like, listen, you've done it, you've proved it.
- Yeah.
- Clearly, you're good at this.
- [Laughing] Yeah.
- You know, like,
just rest easy in that.
Like, it'll turn around.
- Absolutely.
- And of course, if you're thinking about it,
that's already a bad sign.
So you have to kind
of train yourself to just put all your,
you know, for lack of a better,
all your eggs in the basket of,
I already prepared for this. I'm ready.
- Yeah.
- So even if you mess up a little,
you're still prepared.
- Yeah. Like everything that I need
is already in me because I have
done it time and time and time.
- Yeah.
You gotta trust that.
- So it's really about trusting that. Yeah.
- You know, Coach Auriemma is clearly like
a huge basketball inspiration for you.
He's probably molded a lot of the things
that you think, you know, about the game.
He's a fascinating person to me
because it feels like
there is a very wide range
of opinions on Coach Auriemma.
- [Laughing]
- So I have a bunch of questions about him.
But what I first want to say
with the obvious disclaimer that he is
someone that you love and has been major
in your basketball career.
- Of course. Yes.
- When you were in college, did you like him?
- It's a love-hate.
I mean, I feel like everybody with
their college coach has these moments.
He just, he’d push. He's a pusher.
And he really, he pushes you
to places that you didn't know existed.
But that's
when you figure out what you're made of.
And so it's hard to hate it, you know?
But in the moment, yeah.
Of course.
We always joke, like, we’d go to practice.
It's, like, the worst, you know,
two, three, four hours of your life.
And then you go back to the dorm room
and talk shit.
And it's funny cuz we've—you know,
obviously you get older. Your relationship
with your college coach changes
cuz you're now adults.
And we've joked with him a ton, like,
“Listen, just so you know, like,
all we did for four years is talk
shit about you
behind your back in our dorm room.”
And at the same time,
I look at him and I'm like,
“And we know all you did in the coaches
meetings was talk shit about us
after every single day.
So we're on the same page here.”
- Yeah.
OK. No, that makes sense.
So it was a love-hate.
And you understood that
all the things he was doing was
to make you all a better team,
- Oh, yes. Absolutely.
- better player and things like that.
- But it wasn't easy.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. It wasn't easy.
- Because it feels like in a lot of ways,
you are almost mentally
getting beat down there.
I mean, is that accurate to say?
- Not far off. Not far off.
But, you know, it's like,
listen, the stories that, you know,
are fun to tell, the memories
that all of us—when I say we, by the way,
I'm usually referring to, like, my class, right?
- Yeah.
- My generation.
Maybe, like, some teams I played on.
But the same goes
if I'm sitting in a room with Jen Rizzotti
or if I'm sitting in a room with Renee
Montgomery. Like,
we all kind of have this shared language.
And the best stories are the ones
where, like, someone got yelled at,
somebody cried, somebody threw up. Like,
those are the best ones.
But for every one of those—
and I have a great Swin [Cash]
one if we have time later—
but for every other one of those…
- We have time after you say this.
- Um, she’ll kill me.
For every one of those, there's, you know,
three, four, five, six, seven, eight,
nine, 10 stories where, you know,
something happened where he lifted you up
or he had your back.
I mean, one stupid one was I parked my car
in front of my dorm—like, we lived
in these apartments my senior year—
and I parked my car in a handicapped spot
by accident. Like, who knows?
I just wasn't thinking.
- Yeah.
- And we go on the road, and it was like,
get a phone call.
“Your car is in this handicap.
We're towing it.” And like,
I don't even know what happened.
All I know is when I got back,
he handled it. Like, the school,
like, the coaching staff handled it.
And my
car was in the spot next to it.
Yeah. He was like,
boop, boop, took care of it.
- Yeah.
- You know, so it's like,
there's moments like that.
So there's—it's not even a balance.
There's more good than bad.
- OK, because I remember hearing
you talk about a time you were there,
and he calls you in the office,
and he's like,
Every bad thing that happens on
the court is your fault.
- Mmhmm.
- Every good thing that happens is
your fault, but every bad thing.
If this person messes up…
- I didn’t get credit for the good things.
- Just the bad things.
- Like, if this person messes up, if you're not
even on the court, like, it's on you.
- Yeah.
- And I would think for a college player,
that is
an immense amount of pressure.
- Yes and no.
So looking back, like, in the moment,
I really didn't get it,
like, in the moment, in that exact moment.
I was like, “What is he talking about?
That makes no sense.
How is this my fault?” You know?
But now I totally understand that he…so
what he's amazing at—and I
joke about this with him as well;
I’m like,
“you're not the best X's and O's”—
but what he's amazing
at, like, truly amazing
at, is understanding people, understanding
his players and understanding
how to get the best out of them.
And it changes from player to player,
and he bobs and weaves with that,
like, better than anyone I've ever seen.
So I think when he saw me or started
to get to know me, he saw a player
that had that ability to kind of juggle
all of that on the floor.
And kind of have
my hands, my fingerprints on everyone
and everything.
I think he saw that in me.
And so that was him
challenging me in a way to bring that out
because I do have a little bit of a
shyer personality,
especially when I was younger.
So I always joke, not joke.
I always say it's like, “I'm a dip
my toe in the water” kind of person.
Like, let me see
what's going on over here.
- Yeah.
Feel it out.
- Exactly.
- Yeah.
- And he was basically trying
to speed up that process.
- Yeah.
It's like, “No,
you actually have to jump in the pool.
We don't have time for you to dip.
We're trying to win championships.”
- Exactly.
- Yeah.
- Like, yeah. We don’t have time.
I got four years. That’s it.
- OK, that's fair.
That's fair.
It's just there really is, you know,
there's the, the group of people
that feel like, OK, is the way
he's coaching people healthy?
Like, is it a good way for you
to talk to people, you know, mentally?
Can you overcome
maybe this, this environment
of what can feel like a pressure cooker?
- Yeah.
- But it's always interesting
because everybody that leaves
UConn is like, “Well, he changed my life
and he made me a good player.”
So I feel like there's maybe some things
that are misunderstood about it
because we are just seeing, you know,
the press conferences or,
you know, what he says after a game.
- Yeah.
- You know?
- I mean, yeah,
those make me cringe sometimes, too.
- Yeah.
- But I know him,
and I understand there's a method
to the madness.
But I mean, I would say at the same time,
like, times have changed.
People have changed. Kids are different.
- Mmhmm.
- And that's not a bad thing, right?
I see it in my WNBA experience.
- Yeah.
- Like, I'm 41 now.
So every draft class that comes in who's,
you know, they're going to be 21.
I've seen it for the last, like, four
or five years
where it's like a little different
and you kind of, you know,
there comes a point I think with anyone
who is a leader in any position
where you start to see
what's going around. Like, do you adjust?
You know,
do you stick with what's always worked?
I think it's a tough question
as a leader.
- Totally.
- Yeah. So I wouldn't be surprised
if he's thinking about those things.
- Yeah.
And it's probably hard
when you are a proven winner.
- Yeah. It's worked.
- Yeah.
Like, well,
I know that this thing that I'm doing that
you might have an issue with
has got me all these championships.
- Right.
- And sometimes it's
hard to tell somebody that
because they are like, “No, no, no,
you don't know what you're talking about
because I'm the winner.”
And I can see both sides to that.
One more topic
on him before we wrap up
the Geno conversation.
You know, Candace Parker was on the show.
- My pants are noisy. Sorry.
- It's OK. Great fit.
- Noisy pants.
- You know, Candace Parker was on the show.
- Yeah.
- And she talked about her experience with Geno
and the Olympic team.
And essentially saying that she felt like
she didn't
make the team
because her and Geno did not get along.
What was your reaction to that clip
if you saw that?
- Yeah, no, I saw it. Um, man, it's a tough one.
It's tough.
I mean, I think if I'm Candace
cuz obviously I was present
for all the things, right?
Whether it's the, you know, training camp
where she balled out and got MVP.
I was there. I was with her.
They do an
NBC kind of like huge media day.
I was there with her for that,
you know?
- Yeah.
- It's like, when you go to that,
you're kind of like, "OK,
they must think I'm on the team."
- Yeah.
So, and then I was— I texted her
when when they did announce the team,
I texted her right away. Like, I don't even
remember what I said, but I just knew,
Right?
- Mmhmm.
- Of course.
And I think it's one of these things
where it's like, if I put my Candace hat
on, I could probably sit here and tell you
that she should've been on the team.
And then I could probably put my USA
Basketball hat on
and be like, "OK, I understand
why this happened."
- Mmhmm.
- So that is the difficult part
with our national team.
It happened with Nneka this year.
It's always going to happen
because we have that many good players.
It's always gonna happen.
As far as the Coach
Auriemma piece? I mean,
he's the coach, he's not on the
committee, and it's, like,
as an athlete who has been on the team
and who has been selected
by the committee, I wanna believe that
the committee makes these decisions.
It's almost like when you
have to believe in a system.
Like, I'm choosing to
believe in that system.
- Yeah.
- And I'm choosing to believe
that it's working
because we're winning.
Simultaneously,
yeah,
I mean, there's people
throughout the years
that have been snubbed
that are my friends, and it's not easy.
- Mmhmm.
- So it's like all these, it's
like one of those scenarios—
and I think we're finding this
a lot in our society—where, like,
all things are true.
- Yeah.
Or there's some potential
nuance to
the situation and it's not
so black and white.
- Yeah, all things are true.
- Would you, I guess, understand
the perspective of somebody who believed
that there is some sort of favoritism
that is shown…
- For the UConn players?
- Yes.
- [Laughing]
- I mean, I always— so Megan and
I talk about this a lot, the UConn bias,
um, trying to get to the bottom of it.
- [Laughing]
- And she gives me an amazing perspective.
Um, so what's very difficult
as a UConn player is
I think immediately
when you're asked about this,
whether it's the Olympic team
and making that,
whether it's media coverage bias
that a lot of people talk about nowadays.
Immediately as a player,
you think back to these four years
where you busted your ass,
and you're kinda like, we won because,
because we won. Like, the games
are the games are the games.
- Mmhmm.
- Right?
And the Maya Moores, the Diana
Taurasis, the Breanna Stewarts.
I mean, think of these names
I'm saying.
- Yeah.
- These are, like, I could've potentially named the top
three players of all time, right?
- Totally.
- Of course, you can throw in
many names to that;
I'm not leaving anybody out.
I'm just saying,
they're at like the tippy top.
- Yeah.
- So like I said, from a player's
perspective, it's hard to understand.
And I think
you could
also take a step back and understand that
because UConn has been successful,
people are going to…
I was gonna say shine a light on that.
I don't know if that's necessarily
the best way to explain it,
but it's going to be covered more.
It's going to be…
and I see where that's,
like, hard for a lot of people.
And I see—
- And probably annoying.
- Yeah, I'm sure it's annoying.
I mean, yeah, I see it.
But like at the same time, I'm like,
it's the best team. They've been—
forget that
I'm UConn for a second.
Like, it's the best team.
They've been winning.
I mean, the amount of winning,
it's really hard to argue that.
And I think the same goes for the players
that have been on the Olympic team.
- Yeah.
- It's really hard to argue
these names.
They're all-time greats.
- Yeah. That's fair.
And I like this, because
I think whenever there is a topic
like this, it is important
to get all the perspectives.
- Oh, yeah.
- You know,
the way that you see
it is gonna be different in the way
that Candace sees it or Geno or another
UConn player or non-UConn player.
And all of those matter to fully
understand, like, the scope of the topic.
So I think that that really is true.
- I know it's a very politically correct
I feel like what I said,
but at the same time, like,
it's
like I said, I think when I
think about my four years and I'm like,
I mean, we all were like, we all busted
our asked to win those championships.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, so it's hard to like…
- Do you think that there is—
fix isn't the right word—
but do you think that there is a way
for there to be more of a,
I don't know, a confidence or transparency
in what happens with Team USA?
Because it seems like
there are a number of players
that have some sort of issue
with how it works.
- Yeah, I don't know.
It's like, I mean, I really don't know.
There's 12 spots.
- Yeah.
And a lot of good players.
From a transparency standpoint,
I'd have to think about it
because I don't know, like,
I mean, one thing maybe you could say
is do you have more people
on the committee, right?
More people…
I don't know who those people would be.
But like, is that the answer?
Is it too small?
Is it— you know, I'm like,
I really don't know because the—
do you know the answer to all of this is?
- Yeah.
Um, so Megan uses this "kiddie pool" analogy.
It's basically
like what we've talked about historically
with women and opportunity.
And we've always said this pie,
and we're only getting
this small piece of the pie.
And the truth is, it's like,
in a lot of these conversations,
the problem isn't that player X from UConn
is getting more attention
than player Y from another school.
The problem is all of us
aren't getting enough attention.
We all— It's like the,
opportunity for the attention.
The coverage isn't big enough.
So we're all fighting and clawing.
- Yeah.
- For the one article. For the one, you
know, I don't know, a story. For the one.
And so it feels like we're competing
with each other the.
So Megan says kiddie pool because we're
all over there fighting in the kiddie pool
trying to, like, play with the one toy,
and there's this whole ocean.
- Yeah.
- That's the problem.
The problem is
we need to get into that ocean.
So what this doesn't solve
is the fact that there's 12 roster slots
because the answer is, "Oh, we need 15."
- Yeah.
No, I think that's a really
good way to put the,
the problem in a lot of ways
is the system.
- Yes.
And since we are
all kind of living within the system,
you think that the problem is each other,
and really are just
trying to make it work.
- Competitive.
- Yeah. OK.
- We need, like, more.
- Yeah.
- The answer is actually more.
It's not that—and this is—it's
not that, you know—I'm trying to use
some good names—
- [Laughing]
- It's not that Diana Taurasi
gets too much coverage, right?
It's that Simona Augustus
didn't get enough. But
it doesn't have to take from D.
She deserves that, right?
- Mmhmm.
- It doesn't have to take from
Elena Delle Donne.
She deserves it. It doesn't
have to take from A'ja Wilson.
And she deserves it.
It's just that there's players
this, this, this and this that also do.
But there's not enough and we need more.
- No, that totally makes sense
because there is no—
there's not one person on the planet
that is seriously being like,
"LeBron James has done
too many interviews."
- Right.
Nobody says this about the men.
Yeah, yeah.
And that's because it's like,
there's endless places,
so nobody feels like the reason
he's getting it is because he's him and
there's not enough.
It's like, it's all so
there that it's not an issue.
- Right.
That is a, I think that's
a really good way to put it.
And that was very striking to me.
So I hope that people watching
feel like that is true.
- I think that that's what
we're fighting for,
to be honest.
- Yeah.
Yeah.
That's usually, like,
what's playing in my head
just in any conversation
or interview or whatever.
That's like, that's the goal.
- So, do you—and again,
because this is a system that exists,
it's not you specifically.
Do you ever feel guilty
about the coverage that you get?
- Hmm. Sometimes. It's, like,
I don't know if guilt is the right word, um,
because in women's basketball,
there's so many variables, um,
that come into play outside of the sport.
Race being a big one.
Looks being another one. Right?
Maybe it's, I don't know, a huge Instagram following,
but you didn't even make a team
or something like that, right?
- Right, mmhmm.
- Like, like a huge social media—
but, so, there's all these things
that kind of, like,
swirl in women's sports that don't,
either don't swirl the same in men's sports
or what you just said,
because there's endless opportunities—
- Yeah.
- It can swirl. It doesn't matter.
Everyone eats.
- Totally.
- Right? So it's,
it's an interesting—guilt?
Some, it's like, there's a sprinkle of guilt,
and it's more just having that moment
where you kind of take a step back.
You look at what you're receiving, right?
And you're kind of like, OK.
Not about, it's not necessarily
about deserving or not deserving.
I feel like my career
does speak for itself in a lot of ways.
But also, OK, just because I'm white
or also, it's OK because I quote unquote,
look like the girl next door or—so,
you know, those questions pop up.
And the reality is,
this is where I can use the platform.
This is where I can use my voice.
- Yup.
- This is where I can help
create more opportunities
so everybody eats, for lack of a better term.
- Yeah. Absolutely.
And I mean, it's also really important
to say that so much of the platform
that you have has been used
not to shine light on you, but to shine light on everybody else.
You know, whether that's Togethxr—
- Oh yeah.
- And you're giving stories to all girls
and women that are playing sports,
whether it's using your voice
to talk about Black Lives Matter
or equal pay or anything like that,
you have used all the attention
that you get to bring attention
to others that need it too.
But yeah, I do think that's interesting
because, you know,
sometimes you'll see people talk
about the coverage of women's sports
and they'll say, OK, well,
you know,
we only care about Sue Bird.
- Mmhmm.
- And I get that.
But I also—
- I'm like, who says that?
- [Laughing]
But I also understand why. Like,
I don't think that that's wrong.
It just goes back to
what you're saying about
there should be more so that there is
the room to care about every single person—
- Right.
- Because everyone has a really important story
and they're bringing something, you know, to the table.
- Yeah.
- And more than that, it's that, I think it's important
that you even have that awareness
that maybe there are these other things
that are lending to it too.
- Oh yeah, I mean—
- Yeah.
- How do you not?
But I was gonna say the complicated part is, um,
the fact that we all have bias
and kind of trying to sort through
where that comes from
or why it's there or, you know what I mean?
Like, even a fan.
So like, trying to understand—
so it's just, I don't know,
how do you dismantle anything?
I mean, it's a slow, long burn of a grind.
- Yeah.
- But at the same time,
what gives me hope is kind of
what's happened in the last
couple years in women's basketball.
Just, it feels, like, it feels—
usually I'm just like, oh yeah, we turned a corner.
I'm like, it's been a pretty dramatic corner
in a good way.
- Totally. I agree. Yeah, yeah.
- In a very good way.
So that's like, there's hope.
There's a lot of hope.
- Yeah.
- And like, I'm only saying
because you brought it up,
but Togethxr is like, that's where, um,
I feel like I can't wait to be,
once I do eventually retire, I feel like
I can pour so much more into that.
And I'm so excited for that because,
A, it's just, like, fun to be able
to tell these stories and just find out
about the stories themselves, you know,
because even for me, it's like, it's
almost like this, like, unveiling of sorts
where you're pulling back these curtains
and you're like, oh, dang, like this,
you know?
- Mmhmm.
- And so I'm really excited
because I know that can be an extension
of the sharing the platform
and shining lights and things like that.
- No, I love Togethxr.
If you're watching and you don't follow it, go follow.
- They do such an amazing job. I mean—ah.
- I think the storytelling is great. Yes.
- So good.
- They shine a—yeah, shine a light
on so many things, and you learn!
Like, I learn about really interesting
and cool, fun athletes.
And this is something that you and I
have talked about before,
but Togethxr is really good at this.
Not every single time we talk to a woman,
we have to talk about the fact
that they're a woman.
- Thank you.
- Like [laughing],
it's wild that this is the thing
that has any—
for every woman that is doing something
that a lot of men do,
I don't like using the term male-dominated
because I don't necessarily
think it's male-dominated as much as
I just think there's a lot of men.
But you don't have
to only talk to women
about the fact that they're women
or how hard it is to be a woman
or they've overcome as a woman.
- Totally. [Laughing]
- And it's important for content that
includes women to be about what they do.
- Yeah.
- Right?
And so, I just really commend Togethxr
for doing that too.
But how has that idea
kind of manifested itself
in your life and your career?
- Um, in terms of…
- Like only being seen as a woman.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- I mean, yeah, it can—it's a little bit
of an uphill battle at times.
So there's a, there's balance
you have to strike between,
you do need to talk
about some of these things, right?
So like, I do need to talk about
some of these issues
that women face, that women in the WNBA face,
female athletes face.
And then I actually think because sports
mirrors life and vice versa so, so much,
where even though I'm talking about
athletes, like, I'm talking about all women.
- Yeah.
- I'm talking about all women in the workplace,
like all women everywhere.
So there are things because, um,
like the NCAA tournament
with Sedona Prince
and showing the weight room.
If you know that story—
if you don't know that story, like,
you're probably under a rock.
- Yeah.
- So I'm not even gonna explain it.
But what was so fascinating to me about that was
we all, like, know this or knew this.
Every one of us has experienced
that moment where you're like,
oh, the men got that and we didn't?
And yet it just took her saying it.
- Yeah.
- So the lesson there is you have to say it.
Even if it's hard,
even if it's uncomfortable.
You have to.
- Yeah.
- So the balance is you have to say it.
You have to tell people these stories
because they, like, literally just don't know.
- True.
- Now, the reasons why they don't know
are the problem, right?
Like how society is set up,
I guess, if you wanna say it like that.
But then there is this other side where
it's like, I wanna come on a podcast
and I want to—or a show,
and I want to talk about some fun stuff.
- Yeah.
- Right? Because it's not, I'm not like just
this woman grinding away all the time.
- [Laughing]
- Like, I do fun shit too, you know?
- Yeah.
- And I have funny stories and like, you want to just be able to—
and when I watch
men or male athletes do these types of shows
um, where they're,
where they're really just more so
talking about like,
tell me about your life.
It's never about if—they always
get to have the fun stuff happen.
They always get to have the fun conversations.
- Yeah.
- You know, maybe they're talking
about their favorite wine.
It's like, sometimes I'll go on
different interviews and it's like,
it's never gonna go to that place.
- Right.
- And I exit those interviews
feeling like exhausted almost. You know?
- Oh, 100 percent. Yeah.
- I mean, like,
we'll get there. It’s getting there.
I think we're just part of this generation
where we have to do both.
- For sure.
And you're right. It is like this double-edged
sword of like, OK, it's important
for women
to, you know, inspire other women, right,
that want to do it. To
have them understand
what it's like and talking about it
from the scope of being a woman.
But there's also something to be said
about always being seen as a woman first
and what you do second.
Because you work hard to be in this space
because you are a world-class athlete,
you know? And everything
that surrounds
the coverage of female athletes
is either about them being female
or it's about them, like, inspiring
little girls, which both are important.
- Right.
- But women don't exist in this space
in the service of others.
And there's always this very weird line
that’s, like, teetered.
- Yeah.
- It's also like,
Well, you'll inspire little boys, too.
- That is my, that's like my new, not new—
- Yeah.
- That's been, like, my kick for a while
where I'm like, of course,
I want little girls to see
all of us and be like,
“Oh, I could be like her,” right?
And then I want little boys to be like,
“Oh, this is normal.”
- Yep.
- Right?
Like, women in these positions of power
or women succeeding
on the basketball court or in soccer,
whatever it is, like, “Oh, that's normal.”
- Yeah.
- You know, like,
they're not having to at 18
learn about it.
It's like they grew up with it.
And, yeah, I'm still toying.
I was like, I did some speaking thing
where I was like, little girls get to see
it, be it, and little boys get to see it…
And I keep saying, respect it.
I don't know. I'm toying with this.
- Oh, like, what's the right word?
- Yeah.
Like, “see it, be it, see it…”
- Ooh, we gotta workshop that.
- Yeah. We gotta figure that out.
- Yeah. Cuz that's true.
I read this book
by an author named Kiese Laymon.
And in it he talks about how
representation actually works both ways.
Like, in his example was with
Black people saying, you know,
the thing that happens is
you can turn on a bunch of different shows
and see varying
experiences of white people.
But if a person can only see,
like, Black athletes or Black rappers,
they have to actually see something else
to say, “Oh, this isn't just it.”
- Right.
- So you're not just representing
Black people to Black people.
You’re representing Black people
to non-Black people, too.
- Right. Yeah, that makes sense.
- And it's, you know, it's that same thing,
I think, for,
for what you're talking about as well.
I think eventually that will happen.
We’ll get there eventually, but—
- The five-year-olds will become 25-year-olds that make decisions?
- Yes.
- Perfect.
- That's the hope.
That's the hope.
And it's one of the reasons
I really love the commercials
that you do,
specifically the one with Stephen Curry,
because you are presented
as the standard in that commercial.
- Right.
- And we don't see that a lot of the time.
What went into deciding to do that
one specifically?
- Oh, I mean, it was—
I saw the script and I was like, “Yep,”
because a lot of times
they show you the script beforehand.
Obviously, you have to approve it.
And if it's something wild,
you can change it.
And I was like, “No, perfect. Let's go.”
- Yeah, I'm in.
- Thanks, Steph.
- Yeah, like I'm not the token here.
I'm it.
- Yeah.
- Like, I am who they're—even, you know, on the island,
It's like, well, my blue is greater,
you know?
All that's important.
I love any Sue Bird commercial
that is about Sue being the best.
Keep doing, keep doing that.
- I love them because they're funny.
- Yeah.
- Like, that's what to me,
like, if you can—usually humor works
in these wonderful ways anyways.
So it's like, for me,
if you are presenting the female athlete
as the standard, like you said,
but you kind of do it in this,
like, fun, cheeky way.
First of all, it's going to be memorable
because you laughed.
And second of all, it's probably going to stick
and get the point across even more so.
- Yes.
- So I love that all of these have had this,
like, humorous bend to them.
- Yeah.
And I hope it challenges people to realize
men are always the default.
- Yes.
- And that has to change.
You know, women are not like the
the shoot off of man.
It's like, there’s woman and man.
You know, it's not like everything
starts with men at the center.
And if you're not that, you're
just adjacent to it.
It's like these are two separate things
that are, that are equally as important.
But to that point, I wanted to ask
NBA players
if they had any question for you
and wanted advice from you.
They all said yes.
So I have a couple questions
from some NBA players for you.
All right.
First up, Kevin Love.
Kevin Love says, “I'm curious
with Sue being the greatest of all time
how her approach to the game
overall has changed
from when she came out of UConn until now.”
- Dramatically.
I think with each phase of my career,
there's been something I've had to change.
But in the first
10 to 15 years, I didn't really know it.
So there was definitely a point,
let's call it…
it's somewhere
between like the eight-, nine-, 10-year
range of my career, where like
I needed to change, but I didn't know it.
And so I kind of plateaued a little bit.
And it took some surgeries.
I had this period of time
where I had like three different surgeries
in the span of a year.
And that was the first time where
the physical really needed work. Like,
literally my body of work needed work.
And it
was in that moment where I was like, “Oh,
I should have done this
like four years ago.
I should have changed my diet.
I should have worked out different.”
And I think so my point is, like, now
the approach is all about preparation,
and what falls under
that is making sure I'm healthy.
So all the things that fall under that,
some of them I just named,
cuz to me, you can't,
you can't perform at the highest levels
if something's off.
- Totally.
- Now obviously, injuries come in.
Some things are out of your control.
But, like, that has to be the priority,
for me anyways.
And then with that, what that allows me
to do once those boxes are checked,
now I can let what is really, like,
the key to my game
and the key to me as a player,
and that's just letting my instincts
take over, letting my mind
kind of do its thing,
using my brain out there,
being the point guard.
Because I know the physical is there.
I can rely on that.
- Yeah.
- So that's, like—my approach used to be, like,
nothing.
Like, I was just going out there winging it.
- I’m just gonna figure it out.
- Yeah.
Now I'm like, oh, when this is good,
like, when this body is good
and I've taken care of it—
that's actually, to be honest,
that's where all my confidence comes from.
That's the best way to frame it.
- Really?
- Yeah.
When I can go out there and run around
and, like, cut and move and this and that
and not have to think about it,
then I know I can actually play the game.
And some of that has to do with my age
and like, you know, where I'm at,
so it's not the same answer at 25 obviously.
- Yeah.
- But yeah,
my approach now is, like, all about making
sure I'm checking those boxes,
- Yeah.
- so I feel physically good.
- It's interesting, though, because to me,
what I'm thinking is you talking about
having to deal with confidence,
but what you're describing is actually, no,
I already trust everything up here.
- Oh, yeah. That's not a problem.
- Yeah. Everything here
is completely confident, right?
I can go out there and do that
any time, any day.
But I need to make sure this is in check
so that that can perform at the level
that it needs to.
- I got home from the Olympics
this past year.
And, you know,
the Olympics is a little bit of a grind
because it’s a lot of games.
It's not a lot of time together.
So it's, like, very stressful.
It's, obviously,
if you don't win a gold medal, oh, God.
I mean, I don't wanna think about it.
- Yeah
- It's very stressful.
So, I got back from the Olympics, and
I think some of it was just, like, fatigue.
Like, I was tired mentally, physically.
But that last part of the season,
I felt my body go a little bit.
And I think that's actually why—I'm
sure we'll get to retirement
in a second—I think that's really why—
- We will.
- At the end of the
season, why the fans chanting
'One more year' really got me because
I was really thinking about it.
Like, that,
I think it was like a month. That month,
I physically didn't feel good.
So it was, like, if I'm physically not
feeling good, I got nothin'.
I'm not helping anybody, you know,
Which is the case for a lot of people.
- Yeah.
- So it's not special to me,
but that was really when the retirement
question first started entering my mind
because I was just not—things
were just off, and it was kind of, like, oh.
I feel like
when you're 40, it's safe to ask yourself,
like, "Oh, is this who I am now?"
- Totally.
- Like, "Is this who I am physically?"
And that led to a conversation that I had
with my trainer in the offseason
that I'm sure we can talk about.
- OK, trust me. There's a whole retirement bucket.
So all of these will be asked.
But, before I get to the next question
from a player,
- OK.
- You said, 'I was really thinking about it.'
I mean, like, quantify that for me.
Like, what does that mean?
- I went into that—
OK, so, this is, like, everyone,
but athletes
can compartmentalize, like,
nobody's—like, we're amazing.
We're, like, literally experts at it.
- [Rooks:] Yeah.
- OK.
I was walking into that arena
thinking—not knowing—thinking
it was my last game
when we played Phoenix in those playoffs.
I was, like, good chance.
There was a moment—probably we were down.
It was a back and forth game ish,
but they definitely had the lead.
And there was a moment where I was, like,
let's call it early in the second
half where I was
kind of like, this might be your last half
so let's fucking go, you know?'
- [Rooks:] Wow.
- Like, I actually though that to myself.
So that's,
I think that answers the question.
- Yeah. Like you were. Yeah, it was there.
- It was right there.
- It was right—wow.
- I think I was just really tired.
- Well, what's crazy about that story is,
like, the fans literally brought you back.
- I know.
- Cuz you were right there.
- Wild.
- Yeah. Oh, my gosh. OK,
so much more to discuss with that.
But I feel like these guys will kill me
if I don't get to their questions.
Um, OK, so DeMar DeRozan—
you somewhat answered this.
DeMar wanted to know,
"As you get older playing,
what do you do to keep yourself physically
and mentally ready to keep going?"
"Did you change your offseason
workouts, your nutrition?"
You kind of answer the first part, but
did you change anything with nutrition?
- All of it.
All of the above.
- [Rooks:] Yeah.
- I hired a nutritionist.
Honestly, the one thing
Stewie—Breanna Stewart—came to me after her
second year, maybe.
Yeah, after her second year,
and she was like,
"If you were my age, what's the one thing
you would have changed?"
And I was like,
I would have hired boop, boop, boop, boop,
boop, and I would have gotten my workouts,
my nutrition, all the things,
all the things.
I would have done that from day one.
I think that the sooner you do
it, the better.
When you're younger, you think
you can, like, get away cuz you can.
- [Rooks:] Yeah.
- But why not start now?
Like, why not start then and build, but
as the older player, one thing I would add
to maybe, like, give DeMar
like an actual answer is less is more
when you get older.
- Mmm.
- Less is more.
I feel, like, once you have in your own
mind established,
like, what kinds of, you know, workouts
—let's use that as an example—
what kinds of workouts
you need to be ready,
at some point,
you have to have a conversation
cuz it's probably,
as you get older, it's
probably too much on your body,
and you have to figure out
that balance.
So, like, today. Today, I went to the gym, and
I have a clock, and I'm, like, start.
And today, I shot for—
Actually, today was, like, a longer day
and it was an hour,
but I very rarely go over an hour
on the court.
Very rarely.
- Mmhmm.
- Very rarely.
- Don't know if you caught that, but very rarely.
And even that, like—
so, sidebar, training camps
in, like, very soon. It's in a couple weeks.
- [Rooks:] Yeah.
- So, I'm in like full-on, ready
for training camp.
So the answer to
this now is different from a month ago,
but if I answered a month ago,
I'm only on the court
two, maybe three times a week.
- Mmm.
- And like I said, very rarely
do I go over an hour.
- Yeah.
- So less is more.
Now, you want to be efficient,
you need to figure out,
like, ask yourself what things do
I need to get done to feel confident
in my game, and then try to get those done
in an efficient way.
So you feel good, you feel confident,
you feel prepared, like you
check those things on that list,
but you're not overdoing it on your body.
- Yeah.
- Cuz, the whole thing is
being as fresh as possible
for when the season comes.
- Yeah.
And, I mean, I think understanding
your limit is an underrated skill.
- [Bird:] Oh yeah.
- Just in general.
- [Bird:] Yeah.
- [Rooks:] People think they can do everything.
- Mmhmm.
- [Rooks:] But everything in moderation, even moderation.
OK.
- [Bird:] Well, we all think we're, like, 21.
- Yeah. I am still 21 actually, so.
- People will be like, "Oh, you ran track
in, like,
you know, high school, like,
how fast could you run a mile?"
And I give the answer I ran
when I was 21.
- [Rooks:] Yeah.
- I'm like, "Oh sub-six."
- [Rooks:] Yeah. Years ago. Yeah.
- Meanwhile,
I wouldn't be able to smell that now.
- [Rooks:] All right, next question.
Got one from Ja Morant.
He said, "When she watches film,
is she focusing on the stuff that she does
well or her mistakes?"
- Oh, both.
Both.
Probably more mistakes than
well. I feel like if you're doing
something well, you already know that one.
- [Rooks:] Yeah.
- Mistakes,
there's learning to be had.
- [Rooks:] Yeah.
- But I'll be honest,
when I watch film, most times I'm watching
how the other team is guarding us
more than anything.
- [Rooks:] Mmm. OK.
- That's where I can find moments to steal possessions.
- But how did the way you watch film
change as you progressed in your career?
- Oh, um.
Yeah. Early on, I really didn't watch a lot.
It wasn't like a thing.
- [Rooks:] Really? Like, I was just going out there.
- Kind of. Like, we watched with our team.
- [Rooks:] Yeah, yeah.
- But, like,
no, I didn't go back to my—no.
I mean, Synergy and all these fancy
things didn't exist, where you can, like,
just type in stuff and go watch it.
- [Rooks:] Yeah.
- I wasn't gonna like, you know,
watch a VHS. Dating myself a little bit.
Um, but yeah.
I would say it was probably around 2010.
We had an assistant, Jenny Boucek,
who's actually in the NBA with the Pacers,
and we were going into our playoff run, and
that was the first time I ever sat down—
this was with somebody.
Now I do it up by myself—
and watched the games, and it was like,
Oh, we can kill them running that
and we can beat them running this.
And this is how they're guarding that.
So let's do this and all those things.
And then I would make that,
like, mental list.
Sometimes, I'd write it down, actually
keep it in my locker
so I could, like, refer to it.
And it was like, if I can steal two,
three possessions a game
by just using what they're doing
against them, that's six points.
That's a win.
- [Rooks:] Yeah.
- Yeah.
And that I've taken that with me since then.
- OK. No, I love that. Shout out to Ja.
Good question.
All right.
Devin Booker. He goes, "OK, Taylor,
so I know it's off topic,
but I gotta know because she stays clean."
- [Laughing]
- Who is your inspiration for style?
- Style?
I mean, I don't not like all his shit on
LeagueFits.
- Yeah.
- I'll be like, oop, save. I'm like—
- [Laughing]
- I pull from a lot of people.
- Yeah.
Because I definitely like to dress
in a way where I feel comfortable,
I feel good.
And so if it's like a woman
who I see, boop. If it's a dude, boop.
Like, I save on Instagram constantly,
so I'm always just swiping and looking.
Devin, I for sure,
like I said, saved your pictures.
And it really just depends.
It's like what
jumps out and speaks to you.
I do love, one of my favorite stylists is Courtney Mays.
- OK.
- Ugh, I love Courtney,
and she does Chris Paul a lot.
She does a lot of DeAndre Jordan.
But so, Chris, every time, I mean, Chris,
when he comes in, I'm like [inhaling]—
- Stellar.
- So good. So good.
- Yeah.
- So yeah, I don't have—I wish I had this like one inspo.
It's usually just like pulling
from different people.
And I mean, shoutout to Megan.
- Yeah. [Laughing]
- She's, um, she helps me.
But more than anything,
what she did was, like, open my eyes
to the possibility of finding your own style—
- Mmhmm.
- That doesn't have to be necessarily
like anybody else's.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. And it's like, what fits you?
- I feel this way
about how Megan dresses, like,
she has a distinct style, but
I feel that way about Devin Booker too.
- Oh yeah, he definitely does.
- Like, you see something and think,
that's something Devin Booker would wear.
- Yeah. [Laughing] Totally.
- You know, which I, like—that's a feat to really have,
like, your own very distinct
kind of calling card for style.
So that was—
- You start with some Chucks. Then
you're on your way.
- Yes. And the little, the pants,
you know, their lil'—
- Yeah.
- You know,
they're not called that high waters,
but you know how they're a little higher?
- Yeah.
- It's—killing it, Devin.
- Cropped.
- Yes. OK.
Fred VanVleet, I was like,
this is a good question.
He said three keys to making it to 20 years.
- Oh. Man. Um. [Chuckling]
OK, so one key is what
we've already said, which is the whole, like,
nutrition, taking care of yourself.
It's just like beyond important.
- Yeah.
- Low-key, I wanna be like, good genes.
I do feel like some of it's luck,
you know what I mean?
Like, some of it is—
cuz I've had some serious injuries
and, like, I've been able to bounce back,
so some of it is luck.
I know that's a crappy key,
but some of it is that.
I do think you have to be able to
adapt and adjust.
So, and this is probably
the most important, to be honest.
I can't do what I did as a younger player.
I just physically cannot move in
those ways.
I'm not as fast, I'm not as quick.
And I think a lot of athletes,
when that happens—
cuz it happens to all of us.
Like at some point, it happens.
People still,
they don't want to give in to it.
They don't want to accept it,
they don't want to embrace it,
they don't want to adapt to that.
So they just keep trying
to play the same way as they always did.
And then they end up looking,
like, you can kind of see it.
You know, they're like,
oh, they're in their old-person years.
You know, it's like, oh, they,
they got old, you know?
- Yeah. Your face [laughing].
Yeah.
- It's like, cuz it's sad
cuz it happens to all of us.
It's gonna happen—
it's like, it happens to all of us.
But I think a big key for me is, um,
I've been able to see those
moments or those ways
in which things have changed for me.
And it comes with a little bit
of a mourning phase.
- [Laughing] Yeah.
- It's like, I used to beat my pull-up jumper—
- You had a good run. [Laughing]
- Yeah, yeah.
Going right with that pull-up.
You used to be the shit. Now…
Especially, yeah, with my pull-ups,
I don't have, like, the pop,
the one-two quick—
it's just not the same.
And there was a huge mourning phase for me
where I was trying to force it
a little bit and I had to
kind of, like, let go of that.
And I'm trying,
I'm actually like currently trying
to like add
something new to like
maybe make up for that.
We'll see if it works. I'll let you know.
- Yeah.
- Um, but that's like a big part.
So you have to, like, accept
that you're not the same.
Allow yourself
to go through the mourning phase.
And then try to figure out another way.
And just because it's not what you used to do
doesn't mean it's worse.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, but it's like, you hold on to parts of your game.
I think we all feel, like, really proud
of these different areas of our game
that we like developed and worked on
and like are ours, like signature stuff.
- Mmhmm. Yeah.
- It's hard to let go.
- Yeah.
You know, that makes me think of
when I was watching some of your interviews.
This is, I mean, an interview
you did years ago
and you are talking about
when you started playing basketball
and you knew, you know,
you weren't gonna be, like,
the biggest, right?
So you said you had
to find other ways to win.
But now you're still doing that
same thing, like you're having
to find other ways to win
and like, still be Sue Bird.
Maybe not the Sue that we saw,
you know, all those years ago,
but it's still at its core Sue
and how you're switching that up.
So I think that's
really interesting.
The last one is from Donovan Mitchell.
He just wanted to know—
- Greenwich. Shoutout.
- Yes. He just said, how do you keep the same
mindset night in and night out?
- Whew.
- Yeah.
- I mean, honestly,
I should be asking the NBA guys that
with the 80-plus games
they play. That is just,
I can only imagine that some nights you're
kinda like, can't find it tonight.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. It's hard.
Um, I sometimes trick myself.
I…this sounds crazy,
I can't believe I'm saying it out loud,
I've only said it out loud like one other time.
I will literally—
so right now, I have found
crazy inspiration in my nieces.
They're nine and seven.
They're like,
they're starting to understand
what's happening, like, with me
and basketball and, like, what's going on.
They watched the UConn game last night.
- [Laughing]
- They were very excited
wearing my jersey,
which is hilarious.
And I'm, sometimes, when I'm not in the mood
or I can't find it, I'm like,
if they were in the building, like,
what would you be like right now?
You know?
And sometimes it is mind over matter.
I think any of these guys
will tell you that, especially
in like, situations, like a back-to-back.
It's mind over matter, right?
And it's like, one team's gonna let it get to them.
The other team's not.
And that's like the end.
That's like how it's gonna happen.
So I just literally will find ways
to, like, trick myself.
And then what I find is like this
like adrenaline rush
that kind of gets me over the hump.
And then once you like—
- Really?
- Yeah, once you kind of get over it,
over that hump,
it just kind of like, you coast from there
in a good way.
- So you're like, if my nieces and nephews were in here—
- I know, it sounds like Jedi mind tricks.
- This is what I would, this is what—
- Yeah, like, if they were watching me, like,
how would I want to be right now? Like,
what would I want them to see?
I've done it with different people
through the years.
They're just,
they're just right now No. 1 on the list.
- Who's, like, the funniest person you've done it with?
- Um, funniest.
- Or most interesting.
- Yeah. Um, no,
there's been moments where it's been like,
nobody really like that interesting,
to be honest.
- Yeah.
- Moments where it's like, maybe it's
an Olympic year, so maybe it's coming up.
It's like, all right,
if the committee was in here, like,
what would you be doing
if so-and-so were in here, like how would you be,
you know? Cuz there—listen, we all have
nights where you don't feel like it.
- Mmhmm.
- We're not different from anybody else.
But you have to find a way to get over that part.
- Yeah.
Which leads me to, OK, so—
- I sound crazy.
- No, you don't.
I love it.
I feel like we all kind of think,
like, “What would we do?”
So I, like, make up scenarios in my head
that are conversations
I'm never going to have.
Retirement.
- Yes, we're here.
- We're here. We're here.
When will you know it's the end?
- Oh, man. I'm in a real weird place.
Cuz the “one more year” chant,
there was an assumption,
fair assumption, that there would be
one more year, which implies retirement.
And there are moments where I'm like,
yeah, this feels like the right—
this could be the last year.
It feels right for it to be the last year.
And I explained to you
kind of how the season ended
and how I was really tired. And the way
I'm feeling right now is I'm not so tired.
And I actually feel
pretty good physically.
So that's messing with my head
a little bit.
So I do think once the season starts—
and I know it's not, like, fair.
I'm not trying to, like, Tom Brady
or nothing like that.
You know, it's not, like, necessarily fair.
- Yeah.
- Cuz I know a lot is being built around
this potentially being my last year,
which I already know I'm going to like,
Day 1 of training camp
team, team-only meeting,
I'm going to be like, “Guys,
I'm really sorry that there's
going to be a lot of questions.”
- Yeah.
- Like, I'm going to have to have that conversation
cuz I don’t want to be a distraction
or an annoyance for anybody.
But yeah, so I think very quickly, like
within the first like month, two months,
I think I'll have an idea
cuz the grind of the season,
you can't really, you know, imitate that
in your offseason, and
that'll be the story of where I am.
So I think I'll know pretty quickly.
So when you made that decision,
you know, that you weren't going to retire,
and you said you went
and he spoke to your physical trainer,
what was that conversation?
- So basically—her name's Susan.
She's amazing.
And I was basically like, “All right,
Susan, be real with me.”
There's zero—
I'm a person.
I like to live in reality.
Like, do not sugarcoat.
I don't work well with that.
- Right.
- Give it to me
real.
I was like, I feel like, you know,
this isn't as strong as it could be.
I feel like I can't, like, decelerate,
like, slow down in the ways that I need to
to play.
Like, I could feel getting—
I feel like a lot of times
you get a little, like, tippy-toe
because you can't like [beeping noises] as fast.
- Yeah.
- Like, tippy-toe, tippy-toe around the place.
I feel like
I'm tippy-toeing a little bit too much.
So I just got like real nitty-gritty.
I was like,
these are the things that I feel
are, have taken a turn for the worse.
Are they fixable?
Or is, like, this is just what it is?
And that's OK too.
And she was like, “They’re fixable.”
And I was like, “Well, let's go, then.”
And that's kind of been the whole, like,
basis or foundation of my
offseason has been trying
to, you know, for lack of a better
fix or improve in these areas
because
those were the reasons—I was also,
there is the fatigue part,
but, like, that's what I was feeling.
And she was like,
“Oh, no, these are definitely fixable.”
- Yeah. Like, we can make this work.
- Like, we can make this better.
- So the end—and I’m not trying to put words in your mouth—
but it seems like the end would come
when the things
that are happening in
your life cannot be fixed.
- Maybe, yeah.
- Like if it's, if it's these physical
things that are like,
this is gonna be a really hard grind,
it's like, well,
I don't know if—but then that's also like,
what if they can always be fixed?
How much longer?
- Yeah, that is where the problem lies.
- Yeah.
- I'm sitting here feeling so lucky.
My teammate Lauren Jackson,
she retired in…what ended up being
her last season was 2012. And
she's only a year older.
She's a year younger than me.
Sorry. She played much longer.
Like, in basketball years,
she's like 100.
- Yeah.
- Cuz she started
when she was 15, professionally.
But one of the best players of all time
and had it taken away because of injury.
Physically couldn't do it anymore.
And I watched her go through that,
and at her retirement ceremony
she came to Seattle.
We spent some time together, and listening
to her talk about that and what that was,
it was like, woof, man, to have it taken away
when you're not ready.
So I mean, so I'm sitting here very lucky.
But, you know, it's one of those things
where they're both true.
The other thing that's hard
is when you still physically can.
And so now you have
this other kind of decision.
So what's worse: having it taken away—
I think that's worse.
I shouldn't even phrase it that way.
I guess what I'm saying
is like, no decision,
but it's a bad,
or you have to make the decision.
It's on you.
And that's how I feel now.
So I'm lucky, but I know that's part
of—that's where the answer is
and it's tough to get there.
- Yeah.
Like, you're battling with the idea
that what you have is choice.
- Yeah.
- So stopping is on you.
- And continuing to go is on you.
- Yeah.
- So it’s like, which one do I pick?
- I don't know. Maybe
what I'm hoping is that maybe something
outside of basketball starts
speaking to me so much
where it's like,
OK, you don't need the game anymore.
You know, like, there's other things.
And, like, I definitely feel that creeping
in too. Like, other things interest me.
- Well, because I was going to ask,
is there any part of you
that is scared that you almost, like,
don't know who you are
if you're not playing basketball?
- Identity? Yeah.
I mean, there's a reason that whole
saying, like, athletes die two deaths, right?
The one where you actually die
and then the one where you retire.
- Yeah.
- Cuz It's like the death of an
identity.
Yeah. I mean, it plays a role.
I think what I've really tried to do
since I stopped playing overseas,
which was now like six, seven,
eight years ago,
I've really tried to, like,
get out of my comfort zone, branch out,
try things
cuz I don't want that to happen.
I think it's gonna happen regardless.
I remember listening to D-Wade talk
about going to therapy. I started
seeing a sports psychologist right here
this year.
I've only had one session, but
we'll get to the second one soon.
- OK. Yes.
- Yeah.
- Good. I love it.
That’s important.
- Very important.
Cuz it's a lot, you know? Both
this season, it's a lot to juggle,
and then the whole retirement part.
So I know it's going to be hard
regardless,
but I've been trying to set myself up
where I do have something to
then kind of segue into.
- Could we see Coach Sue?
- Uh, I don't know.
It seems kinda hard.
- Yeah.
- I'm not gonna lie.
- It does feel sort of hard.
- It seems kinda hard.
My
answer is if it was just coaching,
I would love to, but it's not.
There's a lot that goes into that.
A lot of politics, a lot of
I mean, we just had a whole thing
about Coach Auriemma
and Candace Parker.
I'm not trying to be that person.
So yeah, but the actual coaching part,
yeah, it definitely speaks to me.
- Yeah.
- But I feel like I just lived this life.
Do I want to live it again?
That's kind of,
that's where it loses me a little bit.
- Also, you know, new arena in Seattle.
- So good.
- Are we going to get a Sue Bird statue?
- I don’t know. Leave that to the mayor.
Leave that to the mayor.
- I know there's maybe some, some mumblings.
- Are you privy to
if that's a thing that will happen?
- No, I'm not privy.
I don't want to be in that conversation.
- You're like, “No, no, no, Taylor. No.”
- I'm good.
- OK. I think we get a Sue Bird statue.
So I mean, I think we have to, right?
I mean, I don't know how you can do this
without one.
She doesn't want to say,
but I'll say I think that there totally
should be a statue.
I do wanna go back to Lauren Jackson
really quick because I know
when you first got to Seattle,
not friends.
- Nope.
- She did not like you.
- She did not like me.
- Did you like her?
- Yeah.
- OK.
But you understood
she didn't like you.
- Yeah.
- You're new kid in town.
- Well, she didn't actually verbally say it
till the next year, but, like,
I kinda caught the drift.
- Yeah.
- I was like, "Mm, you're not fuckin' with me.
What the fuck?"
- But—[laughing]. Yeah.
- Like—
- Yeah, she's like, "You hate me."
- Really.
- But that's interesting—
- Not inviting me places, what is going on—
No, no, no.
- Yeah. OK, I'm like, oh—
- But that was the vibe.
- Yeah.
- The vibe was like, eh.
- But it's interesting because it clicked
automatically on the court.
- Yes.
That part was no problem.
- Yeah.
- And I think about how many people
in all sports
don't actually like each other.
- No. A lot,
- But they make it work.
What is that like?
- So this is why athletes
deserve—more than deserve—
but deserve
to speak on larger issues in our society.
This is what we do.
We sit in rooms with people
we might not like, and we figure it the fuck
out. For the common good. For everyone.
For everyone to feel good about it.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- To achieve, you know, obviously
in my world, it's, like, to achieve
the championship,
but maybe it's to, like, achieve equality.
- Yeah.
- This is why.
- Totally.
- Cuz, like, there's a lotta times
where you don't like each other.
- Mmhmm.
- And, like, I'm not saying
sports is, like, doesn't get messy.
- Of course. There are fights both,
you know, verbal and physical.
I get—and, like, you know,
those are blasted all over the media.
It exists.
- Yeah.
- But at the end of the day, you're
kind of the jerk when you do that.
- Yeah.
- You're the asshole in the room
when you're not putting the team first.
- Mmhmm.
- And that is how we exist. Like,
that is how we all—
that's how that ecosystem works in sports.
And that is always my answer.
Like, that is why
we get to speak on these things.
- Yeah.
- Cuz we have microphones in our face, so.
- Like, are you gonna
ever, like, run for anything?
- No. For office? No.
- [Laughing] She's like, "I'm ending that
conversation—"
- Absolutely not.
- "Before you even ask me, OK?"
Yeah, no—
- Seriously, that's always my—
- Totally.
- Yeah.
- And it's true.
- It's so true.
- Yeah.
I mean, I think in a lot of ways,
though, sports kind of
are like a microcosm of society.
- Yeah.
- And there's a lot of—
- People are like, "Oh, I don't see color."
- Yeah. It's like—
- Uh, yeah, you do.
- Yeah.
- But, like,
that's the thing about every locker room
I'm in. It's like—
that's the thing. You walk in.
Of course you see it.
You have eyeballs. Like, you're seeing it,
but you don't care. Or, like,
you respect people,
you know, or you have tough conversations.
Oh, there's been a lot of tough
conversations in our locker rooms.
- Yeah.
- And it's like,
but because you have a respect,
you're able to have the tough conversation.
- Mmhmm.
- And, like, for lack of a better, like,
get to the bottom of it or figure it out
or come to a good place or, you know, understand.
- Yeah.
- Ugh.
- No, I love it.
I'm into it.
I—you know,
so you probably don't remember this,
but the first time I met you,
it was at this, like,
Uninterrupted event that we were all doing.
- Oh, yeah.
- And we spoke.
And I remember I came up to you.
I was like, "I'm such a huge fan.
Can we take a picture?" Like, you are—even
before, like, we were friends,
I was like,
"This is one of my favorite sports people."
It's like, you,
Candace Parker and Diana Taurasi.
I only met Diana Taurasi once, actually,
at the dinner, Super Bowl week in L.A.
- OK, right.
- Yes.
- Oh, you were there for, like—
- Yeah, for like 10 seconds.
I had to go to a party, but—
- [Laughing]
You did. I can—
- Yes.
- You did.
- I was ready. I was looking good.
- She was ready. She was looking good.
You were looking good.
- But tell me a story about Diana Taurasi
that is, like, indicative
of her personality.
Like, you tell someone this story
about Diana, you're like, "And that's
how Diana Taurasi acts."
- Oh, my God. I don't even know
where to go with this. Um…oh, my God.
There's too many and…ugh.
Indicative of her personality.
Um, I don't—
there's, like, some that I can't say.
- [Laughing]
- That's what I'm struggling with.
I basically just thought of 10, and
like nine-and-a-half of them, I can't say.
- But to be fair though—
- That would be—
- That actually tells you what you need to know about her personality, too.
- But, like, also,
if I did tell them, you'd be like, "Yep."
- Yeah.
- Or, like, laugh, or—you would never—
very rarely—
I feel like only
when she's maybe, like, arguing with refs
do you disagree with her. You're kinda like,
"Oh, yeah, you
didn't foul," or "Yeah, you
got fouled," you know?
- Yeah.
- But no, she, um…
man, I'll–let me—maybe once—
yeah.
- Okay, I'll come back to talk about it.
Before we get to the fan
question section of this,
I cannot go through this interview
without talking about a conversation
that you and I had
that always sticks with me.
Something you've talked about a lot in
this interview is Megan
and just the impact
obviously she has had on your life.
If anybody wonders to themselves,
like, "Hmm, do Sue and
Megan really act like what it seems like
they do online," the answer is yes.
Like, I have been around them so many times,
and the love that you guys have
is just, like, so real and tangible,
and you're best friends.
It's like you just know
everything about each other.
Like, you just know each other
like the, like the back of your hands.
But we were talking,
and I said, "You know, a lot of times when
we're talking about relationships and love,
we are asked, like, why we love that person,
but we're very rarely asked
why we think they love us."
- Yeah.
- So why do you think—
- I'm like, "What did I say?"
- Yeah [laughing]. Why do you think Megan loves you?
- There's a lot of reasons.
- And remind me what I said though.
- You were talking about just like the,
almost like the peace that you feel like you bring.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah. That's what I thought. OK.
- Yeah.
- Um, yeah. So,
I think what I have
brought to Megan's
life is, like, a sense of calm.
And I think—and that goes both ways.
We often say that when we met, we,
like, started talking
and just never stopped.
Like,
a conversation started. It never stopped.
And I think in that conversation,
if you remember, we started dating early—
I'm sorry, late 2016.
Fall of 2016.
She'd knelt,
like, a week or two
after we started talking.
I don't remember the exact timeline.
- Yeah.
- She was also engaged and—ugh.
- It was messy.
- It was eh.
- Yeah [laughing].
You're like, "Uh…"
- Fast forward, fast forward, fast forward.
But it was at a—
- [Laughing]
- Skip, skip, skip.
It was at a time when—I say
that with respect.
- Yes.
- It was at a time when
she had a lot going on.
- Yeah.
- I mean, as you can imagine. And I think
she was—one of the byproducts of that
moment was not being called
into the national team
camps.
- Mmhmm.
- A lot of byproducts, but that was one of them.
And there's this one moment
where, that we joke about now,
but it was like, she wrote this, like,
seething crazy email,
and she was about to send it to the
then-coach, and I was like, "Well, like,
maybe we need to just take a second."
- Yeah.
- And I think that Megan—what makes Megan
so wonderful and what makes Megan
Megan is this, like, just like,
first of all, supreme confidence.
- Totally.
- Never gets embarrassed.
It's impossible.
- Mmhmm.
- You can try. She just does not get embarrassed.
- Yeah.
- And on top of that, like—
I just lost my train
of thought. On top of that, her—
how do I wanna word this? Like,
her—
she follows her instincts, right?
And just, boom, goes with it.
Doesn't think about it, doesn't question
it, just goes. I'm the exact opposite.
I, like, suf—oh, my God,
decision fatigue times a thousand.
- Yeah.
- I, like, cannot—
I mean, I had to choose a flight
to go to the Final Four, and I was like,
"9:00 or 11:00? 9:00 or 11:00?
9:00 or 11:00?!"
I'm like, I couldn't choose.
- Yeah.
- And I think that balance
for us, like, us together is perfect.
- Mmhmm.
- Cuz there is me,
who's gonna, like, weigh it out. Her,
who's just gonna do it.
And together we have
found this, like, amazing balance.
And I think with that, one of the things
that comes from that is this, like, calm.
- Yeah.
- It's peaceful. And I think
there's many ways I
can go in the calm, peaceful conversation.
For some reason, I chose that route.
- Yeah.
No, I think that's important
because it just,
it really permeates from you
two. Just, like, how much you care
about each other.
It's just, like, such a healthy situation.
Like, meeting her—
and if you think about
any other relationships
you've had in your life—like,
how has your understanding of love
changed over time?
- Ooh, good one.
Yeah,
I mean, so this is, I thi—
yeah, this is my longest relationship.
We basically started—she, like, "moved in."
I mean, classic,
classic lesbo behavior.
- [Laughing]
- She moved in, like, immediately,
and we spent a lot of time together.
So it's like, you know,
we both have the same schedule.
So, yeah,
we go work out for a couple hours a day
and then the rest of the day we're together.
- You two.
- Yeah.
So it's been—
I guess, like, my—not my—wait, what was it?
Not definition of love.
What were you saying?
- How has your understanding of it—
- Understanding of it.
Yeah, it's that it hasn't changed much,
but she's definitely taught me a lot.
I think I—I was very independent
because I had to be.
I was living overseas by myself.
You just find ways
to, like, find comfort in
not even—this is speaking for myself, specifically—
not even, like, in myself.
Just, like, I'm comfortable
when, like, the kitchen looks like this,
or when my towels are over here, you know?
Like, when this is happening there.
And Megan came in the house
and was like [moving things around].
And that,
like, got me out of my comfort
zone, but I understood that, like,
it's good to have somebody challenge
you in those ways.
- Totally. Yeah.
- You find out things about yourself.
That this life isn't just about, this life
I'm sharing with Megan, isn't
just about me.
It can't just be about me, right?
I have to—
it wasn't that I'm like, don't think of
her in decisions or anything like that.
But it was like, I have to have even, like,
a larger capacity for that.
- Mmhmm.
- But I think the best part is,
like, to me,
what's so amazing about our relationship
is that we have somebody to
go home to and, like,
talk about some of these tougher issues
and, like, game them out, if you will.
- Mmhmm.
- Like, talk, talk, back and forth, share
feelings, get to the—like,
and you really get to discover
how you feel, and, like, to trust somebody
in that way, like, that's a different
understanding of love. Like, that trust.
And that's just one example.
Like, there's obviously tons of examples
that I could give you within the trust
part of it, but, like, that trust? That to me
is like this whole other level of love
that I don't know that I ever experienced.
- Yeah.
And, like, the trust between you
two, the comfort between you two.
I think what really sticks out to me
is just that you both clearly feel
like you can be exactly who you are
with each other.
- Yes.
- And I know in the, like,
the article that you did with "GQ,"
and you talk about how,
you know, you hadn't,
like, publicly come out
and you were dating her and—
but I guess, like, does love
make you feel free
or did this, like, journey to freedom
that you were on lead you to love?
- Hmm. Good question.
Um, I think what—I think
meeting Megan, starting to date Megan,
falling in love with Megan—
and this is, like, specifically to Megan.
Like, who Megan is and what she has pulled
out of me,
that has—the freedom, like, lies there.
Like, she allows me to be—I mean,
the ways in which she, like, hypes
me up is wild. Sometimes I'm like—
- She—yeah. We are—
- I'm like, "Stop it."
- We have a group chat, and the group chat is all Megan—
- I know. She's—
- Hyping up Sue.
- Hyping me up. I can't. And it's, like, my worst nightmare.
- [Laughing]
- I'm like, I can't.
But like that, I get that every day.
- That's great! Yeah.
- You know, I'm not always comfortable in it.
I'm working on that.
But she, like, really sees that in me
and believes that in me.
And so that, seeing myself through her
eyes, has, like, opened up
all these other doors for me.
- Yeah.
- And I know
that's like talking about myself in this,
in the relationship. It's kind of—
but like that's also, that's like this
other—that's been the freeing part for me.
- Yeah.
- So I don't know—
and it's not just cuz she thinks I'm
amazing,
though it's great
when somebody thinks you're amazing.
It's not that. She's like—it's
not just, "Oh,
I feel good
because somebody thinks that way about me."
It's like it's actually opened my eyes
to things.
- Yeah.
- Like, and I think as an older athlete,
as an older woman, a female athlete,
I have, like,
PTSD in a lot of ways. Just from, like,
the ways we've been treated.
It does—it's weird.
It plays out, or it shows up in all these
different ways at different times.
And Megan will be like, "Oh,
that's your PTSD."
- Mm.
- And I'm like, "Ohhh." But anyways, some of that PTSD was like—
I kind of, like, digested it in a way
where it was affecting how I viewed myself.
And so she's really, like, helped
rewrite that for me.
So that's, likem very freeing.
- Yeah.
Like, she has helped
you see yourself the way she sees you.
- Yeah.
- Which I think is like probably
the most beautiful marker of love.
- Yeah. And it's become where I'm actually seeing
myself that way, like, separate from her.
- Yeah.
- Not even through her eyes. It's
through my own eyes. But, like, it's
opened them to these things.
- Yeah. Oh, that's beautiful.
I love it.
Well, like I said, literally,
if you're around them, you think,
"How were these two ever not together?
How did their lives ever
not have both of them in it?"
So, I mean, y'all are just, y'all are the best.
We have fan questions.
- [Producer:] A bunch. Most—right now, everyone's asking
how can they get into your group chat.
- [Both laughing]
-  I mean, I feel like Sean
Feeney is, like, head of the group chat.
- Oh, yeah.
- But no, our group chats, they're very good.
- They're good.
- They're very fun. Our dinners are probably better
than the group chats.
- The dinner are better.
- Epic dinners.
- But we'll talk. Give us their contact.
We'll figure it out.
- [Producer:] OK, a lot of questions about your shoes.
What are in your—
what's in your rotation right now?
Favorite shoes growing up.
- Ooh.
- [Producer:] Ideal basketball shoes as a kid.
- Here, want me to repeat it?
- [Producer:] Yeah.
- So they can—just ideal basketball shoes growing up,
talk about your sneaker collection,
all the things.
- All the things.
- Yeah.
- My favorite basketball shoes growing up
were the Uptempos. Really every model,
but the OG
model's, like, my favorite.
They actually came, like rereleased
those maybe,
like, a couple years ago and I was like,
oh, swooped them up, went to play in them.
Oh, my God.
- [Laughing]
- I took them off 15 minutes max.
I was like, this Nike technology is legit.
- Oh, yeah.
- Cuz these are trash.
They're from, like, '95. So it's, like,
these are so trash.
So now it just shows you how.
- Yeah.
So when they talk about, you know, wires
and hyperwares and things, like, it works.
- Yeah. OK.
- And right now, like, nothing,
I feel like the Sacais.
- Yeah.
- The VaporWaffles. And they're, like, undefeated.
- OK.
And I know, like, for your basketball shoes,
you, like, only wear Kyries, right?
- Yeah.
- Like, that's your go-to.
- Kyrie's my guy.
That's my go-to shoe.
- Yeah.
And he, like, takes care of you with the shoes.
-  I'm fresh.
- Yeah, he keeps you fresh.
- [Producer:] Can you
talk about your involvement
in Trans Week of Visibility and Action
and this hoodie collab?
A lot of people are excited
about getting their hoodies and kind of
what you're doing with that.
- Can you talk about your, what is it?
- [Producer:] Involvement in Trans Week of Visibility
and Action.
- Can you talk about your involvement
with the Trans Week of Visibility and Action
- Yes.
- and the hoodies and everything?
- Cuz it's…
- Yeah.
- So Megan and I have partnered with UNINTERRUPTED.
We've done a hoodie before.
It's called "Love Is," is kind of how we reference it.
We've done hoodies before.
Now, the beauty of this project
is it's actually the first step
in this huge collaboration where it's
gonna be hopefully year-round.
So, you know, you hear about Pride Month.
Now we're trying to make it, like, Pride
every day,
- Yeah.
- all day, all year.
And again, this is the first step, and
the trans community is being attacked
right now in awful ways.
A lot of them in, you know, political ways,
like legislation and different bills.
And they're basically in my mind
and our opinions, or not opinions, in our
what we think is fact.
They're using elite
athletes to, as a vehicle
to scare people,
to create this, like, fear mongering to
then get these bills passed that
hold kids out of sports, which is really
just hurting little kids' lives.
And so this is our way
of bringing visibility to it.
And I think the best way to say it is
we all know a gay person.
I feel like everyone can be like,
oh, yeah, I know this gay person,
or you see a gay person on TV.
And I feel like everyone would say,
"Of course gay people should have a chance
at a healthy life."
Sidebar before I continue. Part of the
whole attack on trans people in sports.
That's not what this is about.
This is about bathrooms and health care.
That's the next step to this.
So what you might think is just, oh,
keep them out of sports.
No. This is to, like, directly hurt them
in ways that affect their lives,
their mental health.
So with that in mind,
everybody would agree
gay people deserve all the same things,
all equality.
And so what politicians and different
people are able to do is tap into the fact
that a lot of people
either don't know a trans person
or are unaware of knowing a trans person.
So then they're able to create
that fear in the unknown.
And so what this
hoodie is doing is bringing out awareness,
bringing that visibility.
And that is the goal.
- Yeah.
I mean, it's kind of like what you were
talking about in terms of seeing it.
- Yes.
- Like, feeling like there is a relatability
there, and like, oh, this is,
I understand.
- Right.
- No, I think that's super important.
OK.
And the hoodies.
How do they get the hoodies? I guess that's
another question.
- Yeah. They come out,
oh, my gosh, I should know this, it's in my calendar.
I think they come out either tomorrow
or the next day.
- Soon.
You can get the hoodies soon.
- Soon, yeah.
And like, I forget the percent, it's like 10 percent
or so goes to different charities.
- OK.
- Yeah, yeah.
- That's the vibe.
- Any more?
- [Producer:] OK,
we have a show on B/R called "The Portal"
that puts
veteran players up against current players—
- Oh.
- [Producer:] In a fake world.
Who would you wanna
go up against in "The Portal"?
- Uh, what basketball players?
- Who would you want to play in "The Portal"?
So I never got to play against
Cheryl Miller,
and I feel like, I shouldn't even say,
I think I'd like to play with her.
- [Laughing]
- Like, I already know what happens
if I played against her.
Cheryl Miller.
- OK.
- Yeah.
I never even, you know, it's like,
you know, I never even got to see her play, period.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. Just, like, grainy footage
every now and then.
- As we're talking, I had asked Klay, like,
if he had a question.
He goes, "I actually have a question.
I love Sue."
- I love Klay.
- I said, "OK, what's the question?" Like, I'm with her
now. You're out of time.
- I love you too.
I love Klay.
- OK, well. You're too late.
- I love Klay.
- Klay is the best.
He has a very funny, like, dry humor,
personality.
OK, perfect.
- That's the homie.
- Any more questions?
- [Producer:] Yeah, this one's really important.
Whataburger, In-N-Out or Shake Shack?
- Whataburger,
In-N-Out or Shake Shack?
- Is this like bench, start, trade?
- [Laughing]
- I've never had Whataburger, so that's out.
Man, tough.
I think I'm gonna go Shake Shack.
- Ooh, OK.
- But that's not a knock on In-N-Out.
You know what is underrated at Shake
Shack is that Chicken Shack.
- Oh, I've never had that.
I just think…
- They have a chicken sandwich.
And it's so good.
- It's the sauce for me. It's the sauce.
- It kind of has the sauce on it, though.
- OK.
- It's good.
- It's good? OK.
- Yeah.
And then a little hack is going
there breakfast time and getting
just, like, the egg and cheese biscuit but
asking them to put chicken on it.
- On top of it?
- Well, a chicken biscuit for breakfast.
- Is this, like, a JFK terminal situation?
- Yes, literally
that one right across from the gate.
Hundred percent.
- [Laughing]
- I get it
all the time from there
when I have to, like, fly to L.A.
early in the morning
and I need some breakfast.
- We all know Terminal 4.
- Yes.
- [Laughing]
- Klay put his question in.
- OK.
- We, I know we're doing fan questions.
We have a question from Klay Thompson.
"As an ocean enthusiast,
where is the best
spot for seafood in the 206?"
- You want to give yours a shout?
- RockCreek. Shoutout RockCreek. Went there last night.
It's very good. Go get that mussels
bruschetta.
Thank you very much.
What about for you?
- I would say…if you want, I would say, mhm, this is tough.
Cuz you can go,
like, classic, like, you know,
oysters, crab, that kind of a vibe.
There's a bunch of places like that.
But there's this one place
called Walrus and The Carpenter.
If you like oysters, Klay,
this is the spot.
And they do a bunch of other, like, fun
dishes.
They actually have a fried oyster that's
bomb,
- Ooh.
- a bunch of other seafood dishes.
They have other things
besides seafood, but oysters
and kind of, like, a quintessential Seattle,
kind of, like, chill vibe.
Walrus and The Carpenter.
- OK. I love that.
And he has a second question that I'm
not going to ask cuz you addressed it.
He said, "How is she able to play decades
at such a high level, surviving the wear
and tear of season after season?"
But the reason I'm telling you is
I think it it really speaks
to what everybody sees in you,
- Yeah.
- which is that she's still doing this,
and it's still working, and she's still, like,
one of the greatest.
And I just want to take a minute
for that, like, gravity to really sit in.
Because something I always think about
is this interview that
Denzel Washington did.
And someone asked him,
"What are you most proud of in your career?"
And he said, "The career."
- Yeah.
- Like, I'm proud of the longevity and the things
that I was able to do within it.
And I have seen so many interviews
where you're talking about, like,
I feel like I have something to prove.
Like, even now, I'm, like, wanting to prove things.
So with this existing, this, like, great
longevity that you've had, the respect
that you have amongst your peers, what more
could you possibly have to prove?
- Yeah,
so there's,
I feel like there's always in the back of my head
this, like, proving that this isn't a fluke,
right?
Like, proving that, you know,
there's a reason or proving—
But I have to be honest, I think it's, like,
starting to shift, which is probably
also like, whoop, time to retire,
but it is starting to shift a little in that—
and this is when I usually quote
or use one of Kobe's quotes,
which was talking about legacy
and speaking about how, I don't remember
the exact quote, but he was basically
saying there's gonna be another MVP.
There's gonna be—
and so for me, it's, like, someone's
going to break my assist record.
There's gonna come a point guard
that wins more championships
and does more things. Like, it's just,
this is what it is.
This is sports. It's evolution. That's cool.
So what is legacy really? Like,
what else do I have to prove, really?
And we touched, we talked about it earlier
when you were saying, like,
is there the guilt that comes in?
And I think that's kind of where
my legacy lives now.
Like, what can I do
both from a bask—like, specifically a
WNBA basketball standpoint to make sure
this league is, like, in a good place
and it's, you know, not just surviving
but killing it. Like, what can I do?
And I feel like I can share my experience,
and I can speak up.
Another part of it is, like,
how can I help
create more opportunities?
And so it's, like, with that guilt,
I just know at the same time
I can kind of, like, push that to the side
because I know when I am in these rooms,
I can guarantee you and I can promise,
I guess is a better way of saying it,
that I am making sure it's
not just me getting this, right?
- Mmhmm.
- Like, I'm trying to actively,
when I'm in these rooms,
use my voice to make sure
more opportunities are created.
So even though it might feel,
you know, like, one person, one
athlete is getting that, it's, like, that's
where I feel like I know I can
really help create difference.
And that is legacy, right?
That is what my career will also
have connected to it.
- That's so powerful. I love that.
Any more fan questions?
- [Producer:] Who do you think is going
to go first in the draft?
- Ooh.
- Oh, "Who do you think is going to go
first in the draft?" was the question.
- So D.C. has the pick.
Mike Thibault is like a [kissing sound]
"chef's kiss" drafter.
So whoever does go,
you already know he did his homework.
I might say, oh,
I think they kind of need NaLyssa.
It's really between
NaLyssa Smith and Rhyne Howard.
I think they might need Smith
a little more cuz they kind of
are set in their guards.
But I'm telling you, if he picks
Rhyne Howard, he sees something.
- Yeah?
- Yep.
- Oh, I love that.
- He's an excellent drafter. Excellent.
- I have a question.
I mean, I guess I've had questions this whole time.
- [Laughing]
- It's my show, but.
[Both laughing]
But you have not won a championship
in an odd year.
- I know.
- It's 2022.
What we feeling about this
year?
We've got an even one.
The cards are on your side.
- They are.
They are. I feel, I mean, oof.
I feel OK. I never feel good.
So it's like, any year we've won,
I've never felt good.
So maybe it's a good thing
I don't feel good.
But we have, like, essentially same people
back. Like, core group.
Some pieces have changed,
which it's always sad to see people go
that you've spent time with,
but we added a lot of new players
with a lot of talent, so I'm excited.
- OK. I'm excited.
I'm gonna come back
- Oh, you're definitely coming…
- to Seattle.
We're gonna get the whole group chat
to come to Seattle.
- Oh, 100 percent.
- For the game but also for RockCreek.
- Yes.
- Also to try that mussels bruschetta.
That was amazing.
I'm like, can I get, like, a RockCreek sponsorship?
- It was good.
It's good.
- It was so good.
And those beignets, you know,
the beignets were bomb.
But there's, like, a lot of places here
you can get beignets.
But I'm going on to a total tangent.
You were fantastic.
Thank you so much for doing this.
I know we've been talking about,
OK, when are you going to come on, oh,
you made it work.
- Yeah, I'm glad it could work out too.
- I'm so happy I got to come to Seattle.
Everything that you see,
I just feel like I soak in
and people can learn so many things
from you and your experience
and just everything else left
that you have to give.
So I appreciate your time.
And I wore sneakers
just for you.
- I saw that. Yeah.
I'm like,
you picked good ones too.
- Thank you, Sue.
♪♪♪